well joining us now is the Liberal
Democrat leader and former business
secretary at sevens Cable thank you very
much being with us
and I'm keen to get your reaction first
of all to this news from the Sun well
it's very worrying for the Northeast and
the workers and their families um and I
think that's the utmost concern but I
think it does raise fundamental
questions about the brexit strategy I
mean five years ago I was going a
Secretary of State who opened new models
in this and they were very optimistic
they thought Britain was a great place
to be they saw Britain as the Gateway to
Europe that's why they were here and now
they're pulling their investment despite
the fact that the government a year ago
actually was offering them lots of money
to build new models here I mean it is a
rather tragic story we don't know we
don't know I mean it could be about
diesel cars but it can't be okay and the
EU is not really the best market to be
selling these well in fact there is a
problem with diesel vehicles and this
particular SUV was a diesel model but as
I understood it they could have switched
to petrol and did this the reson petrol
version of this so that is it best a
partial explanation and it does raise
the question about why the government
was offering them lots of money to
reduce a polluting car if that was the
case no I think I think bricks is
clearly a major factor it may be one of
several but but certainly a major factor
it's not just for Nissan them and the
same calculations have been made
throughout the car industry I mean if
you are in a Vauxhall or BMW Mini you
know we've already seen jugular Land
Rover cutting that for a mixture of
reasons including brexit and in the
whole industry is now rethinking its
approach because originally saw Britain
as a gateway to Europe and that gateway
is now closing I mean a big part of the
story as well is the fact that the
government gave these assurances we
don't know what the Shura Shura is were
and to no sound to try and shore up the
investment in the future to the UK as a
forward business secretary can you give
us a bit of insight into the kind of
thing that the government would have
been saying well I've been trying for
the the last year or so to find out
exactly what those assurances were of
course there is a limit to what
government can
because of state aid rules but I'm quite
sure that they had found a way of
offering this and money to invest here
with dear mother
well money guarantees support for
research they're all kind of different
ways that you can do this within the
rules but the the reason that I think
that they focused on this sound is that
Nissan are symbolically massively
important if we go back mrs. Thatcher's
debt is the big turnaround in British
economy occurred when mrs. Thatcher
persuaded Miss Anne to come and invest
in the Northeast very much based on
Europe being part of the single market
as it as it subsequently become and it's
become a kind of totem of the success of
British manufacturing based on so if if
they pull it I mean that is a massive
psychological blow as well as an
economic blow to the Northeast and
you're talking about the uncertainty
about brexit and the fear of no deal we
don't know what the situation is of
course I'm particularly Nissan and but
the fear of no deal is certainly
something that businesses are talking
about a lot so my question to you is why
is it that the Lib Dems are still
pursuing the unicorn of a second
referendum when it's pretty clear that
there's no majority in parliament Fred
there's only two months until bright
said would it be better if you should be
focusing your attention on trying to get
a brexit deal over the line that
actually does manage to safeguard jobs
as much as possible well it isn't a
unicorn I mean this is a question of
timing I mean I think what is going to
happen is that Theresa May will bring
back her deal to Parliament I think it's
very unlikely to pass it might but I
think it's very unlikely at the
Parliament certainly is going to reject
No Deal and half the cabinet's as well
well they haven't so far majority to
reject the farm because the majority of
the options haven't crystallized I think
we may get to a point and it will be a
few weeks from here where the government
may itself come to the conclusion that
the only way of getting its deal to
progress is actually to take it to the
country I think Buddhists can change
very quickly in Parliament once they see
what the options are the idea of going
back to the public and giving them the
choice
of the government's deal or some
variants of it as against remaining in
the European Union will soon seem a very
attractive one and I think it is
potentially very live though currently
it is a question of timing now you've
said that you'll step down when brexit
is either stopped all resolved and
there's reports in the papers today in
the mail and Sunday that the government
is planning to potentially call a snap
general election in June so if that does
happen will you leave the Lib Dems into
it quite probably yes I have said indeed
I said I had a series of tasks which
indeed were to complete the the brexit
argument it may not be resolved by the
end of May or certainly not by the end
of March a two-carat take us through
local elections and into an early
general election so I think it's it's
very likely yes but we there are so many
uncertainties at the moment and I mean
some people will be thinking that you
know you've obviously waited a while to
to get this job and as the leader of the
Liberal Democrats but at the same time
you've struggled to really make an
impact haven't you I think we've made a
lot of progress actually I mean if you
look at what's happening on the ground
as opposed to speculation about the
future polls don't suggest that they do
they well the polls do actually if there
have been a lot of local polls within
which we do extremely well the national
polls are not spectacularly good but
they're certainly better than they have
been for the last eight years and the
most recent one I saw the last weekend
suggested that if the labour party stick
to their present course we finish up in
the 20s mid twenties I mean there is a
lot of optimism the party we're at
record levels of membership people in
our joining us in disgust at the Labour
Party and I'm very positive I think
we've made real progress and if there is
another election will lose surprisingly
well
there also I mean there's there's
constant chatter isn't there about the
possibility of a new party being formed
and with speculation that imported into
the minute-hand vacatur the center
ground there's a story in The Observer
about its day saying six Labour MPs are
effectively poised to quit the party and
do just that so have you been approached
by MPs from from other part
yes and they have been I mean it's well
reported for months that there is a
actually much bigger group of Labour MPs
not just six who are deeply unhappy with
Corbin's leadership and don't see
they've spoken to you about it then oh
yes indeed
well this conservatives as well as so
it's not just labour party what do they
set you I think as of now they're
basically working with us just stop
wrecks it to try and get people's vote
there is a very strong group of people
working as a team to try and deliver
that I think when the brexit issue is
resolved or one way or the other
I think they will reconsider their
position in the labour party I can't
predict exactly what will happen but I
think there's a real chance of a
significant group breaking away and if
that happens we will work with them in
some form and what does that mean then
does that mean that they will join the
Liberal Democrats or does it actually
mean that the Liberal Democrats will
effectively be subsumed into another
party no we're not subsumed into
anything but I don't know exactly what
form this could take it partly depends
on the events of the next few weeks
actually around breaks it could be a
coalition not standing against each
other it's not the kind of thing you're
talking about well they're all kind of
possibilities but I think where there
are common values we will operate
together it's very difficult since
that's up a new party under the
first-past-the-post system I think they
recognize that and it will be sensible
if we do have common values and common
interests that we work together in some
way but but that's somewhere down the
track how many MPs are we talking about
I don't know the figure of six this
morning seemed very much at the lower
end of the fingers quoted to me but
again we'll see it's that's their choice
not mine
okay thank you very much